you go dad
thank you my dear the john family have
lived a life
of racism in britain from generation
to generation augustus now 76
has witnessed discrimination both on the
streets
and during his working life he
completely rejects
today's findings it's not that i was
expecting very much
but i was i wasn't expecting so little
and so little that sensible
yeah it's very difficult to see how they
could come
to the conclusion that they arrived
especially given
the huge amount of research there is
over the years
um of issues that cannot be explained
other than by the structural racism that
is endemic within the society
his daughter has had her own struggles
and has already started having
conversations
with her 10 year old i've had to have
discussions with hope at the age of 10
that no parent wants to have with a
child under the age of 16.
these images were too powerful for the
government not to respond
so boris johnson commissioned a team to
find out how we can level up
inequalities
[Applause]
but even today there were protests
students at an academy
just a mile from westminster staged a
walkout
claiming new rules discriminate against
muslim and black pupils
the school called it an isolated event
and are working to resolve the issues
the scapegoat groups within our school
for example
his uniform policy doesn't allow afros
or
any styling of the hair like in terms of
lines he's
put rules on hijabs as well and so
kind of taking the identity away from
students being young
black and british isn't easy for adele
she felt hurt
by what the government is calling a
landmark report
i think it was quite irresponsible it
was kind of like a middle finger up to
towards any ethnic minority because
it really just stated we have not
listened to anything you said
the responders giving evidence to the
commission repeatedly described
systematic systemic and structural
racism
but the report itself concluded that
institutional racism
doesn't exist in britain a question we
put
to the government the report looked at
disparities and what was causing them
and it did find evidence
evidence of discrimination and bias but
actually quite a lot
of the disparities they did find were
not to do with racism and to do with
things like class
geography wealth and so on
the disproportionate deaths of people
from ethnic minorities
will remain a legacy of the pandemic
midwife beenish
feels this report has knocked back years
of building better race relations
in the nhs it makes me upset it makes me
feel like i don't have a voice
i feel like i've been silenced because
i'm trying to care for and make
services equitable for the people i care
for
but it's almost invalidating the
publication of this review was meant to
be a moment of tightening divisions
but it's clear there is now anger
disillusionment
and disappointment among those that want
to see nothing
but solutions insane rasheed sky news